Okay.
I want today to do the impossible and talk about urbanization and urban growth,
um,
in 50 minutes,
but it builds on what you're reading.
And I'll give the classic example,
which is the greatest project of,
of intervention,
of human intervention or rebuilding that as you're building a Paris by that man
that my late friend Richard Cobb wants distance,
the essay l station,
the Tila.
Um,
but in doing so,
I want to emphasize a couple of points.
One is that the 19th century was a period of phenomenal urban growth and
urbanization.
I will distinguish those in a minute.
Um,
and secondly,
that one of the things that emerges out of this urban growth and urbanization,
but particularly the growth of cities,
large and small and medium in the 19th century is an inclusive and in creasing,
uh,
geography of class segregation.
Um,
and the theme of course in Paris as in other cities,
London's a good example is,
uh,
a more prosperous west and the Le increasingly less prosperous east.
Uh,
but also,
uh,
one of the things that I really enjoyed talking about and trying to,
help people understand is why it is that European suburbs are not at all like
American suburbs.
Uh,
why is it that that so people feared by elites were perched on the edge of
European cities,
whether it's Vienna,
whether it's Paris,
where there's lots of other places and not in the center.
Well,
whereas in the United States,
uh,
you know,
if you think of the,
the,
the riots in 1967 before your time,
most of your times,
uh,
in Detroit or Newark or in watts or east la,
I was people in the center with the,
with the,
with the wealthy people in the,
in,
in the periphery,
sort of fearing the,
uh,
the,
the poor people living in the center.
Why is it just completely different?
I remember in,
I dunno,
the 1990s,
early 1990s,
[inaudible] we're doing a book,
I just,
a bunch of essays and France called Bondo,
who's,
which means a red suburbs and I was supposed to write something.
So we're tying to book together.
And it was at this time of the Rodney king trial.
And most of you are not of the trial Rodney King,
but when Rodney King,
who was a Afro American who was beaten up by cops in La and it was filmed by
somebody who just happens to have a,
you know,
a camera and was filming this and there was a big trial,
um,
and the police who beat the hell out of them were acquitted,
you know,
any requested by a white jury,
um,
in the suburbs.
And so I,
and people would,
France couldn't get more of that.
The idea of,
of Sir wealthy people living in the suburbs as opposed to poor people living in
the suburbs in Europe.
Uh,
and so we had to sort of hold the book for,
you know,
for a of a couple of weeks or until I could figure out what,
how to explain this.
Uh,
and so that's one theme also,
uh,
in,
under the rubric of Center and periphery.
And why,
why are European cities different?
Well,
a human intervention has something to do with that in the case of Paris.
And that's fun to talk about.
And so I'm going to do that in the last half of the talk,
but I just,
um,
uh,
a few points at the beginning and I sent around.
I hope that it will reach you something.
I sent out it at a 10,
16 on this a class server,
which has the most of these terms on the board.
Okay.
Um,
the 19th century is a period of both urban growth and,
uh,
or urbanization.
What,
why are those different?
Urban growth is say,
well,
population of,
in any city population of Vienna,
uh,
it rises from say,
500,000 to a million.
I don't remember the statistics that that is urban growth of Vienna is bigger at
the end of the 19th century,
and then it was at the beginning of the 19th century or
any place you want to pick.
But the most important point is that that there's an ink,
there's urbanization in the 19th century.
So you could have urban growth.
Absolutely.
Uh,
and d urbanization.
If at the end of any period that you're looking at,
you had more people living in cities,
but they represented a smaller percentage of the population.
So you could actually have d urbanization if you had more people living in the
countryside at the end of the period,
relatively to those living in the cities.
Um,
so,
uh,
but it depends on how you define what is an urban area.
You know,
in the case of France,
which we know where the hell all these great censuses all the time,
um,
in the restoration that is 18,
15,
1830,
as city had 1500 people in it in 80.
I mean,
there's that many people lined up at the Milford Mall when it a war,
you know,
when it opens,
in this country,
uh,
in 1841,
they start using 2000 people,
uh,
agglomerated that is living in an urban church,
the steeple,
open up the church and look at all the people or whatever.
But you don't need this an urban area.
Um,
you know,
in the United States,
I don't have no idea what they,
they,
uh,
a city a used to be 5,000,
I think it may be 25,000,
something like that.
It doesn't matter what you,
depending on what you call urban,
define as urban,
there's a remarkable increase,
uh,
in the,
the urban population in the 19th century.
And it's not just big huge cities like Naples or Constantinople or London,
which is so enormous compared to Paris compared to anyone,
any cities spatially.
Uh,
but it's also small towns that increased because in size,
because of a industrial commercial,
uh,
administrative functions.
I mean,
so all this is perfectly obvious,
but it's the 19th centuries,
the growth of,
of big,
big cities.
And the first conurbations,
uh,
that is cities that just sort of run into each other,
such as now,
for example,
you know,
Boston to,
to Washington is practically a conurbation and mean.
France would be legal to acquire who bay,
uh,
you know,
in,
uh,
north of England would be Manchester and it's expanding a suburbs.
All right,
that's all perfectly obvious.
Um,
so the next step is to say,
no,
where does the population of of cities come from?
Who are all these people that are increasing the of cities and are part of this
process of,
of,
in a statistical sense of urban growth.
And second point that I'll make is what did people think about this?
I mean,
what did they think about these teaming cities?
Teaming was a word that they started to use to describe these cities that seem
to be kind of runaway,
runaway cities.
Um,
okay.
First of all,
um,
I'm not going to write this on the board because it's probably it,
but despite the fact that the only mathematical formula that I even know that if
you were trying to explain,
uh,
the growth of,
of any city from 0.1 and time,
2.2 in time,
uh,
what you do is simply look at the population of 0.1 in time,
say 18,
11 or something like that.
And then,
and then you try to find out where the population came from.
Uh,
that increased it to point to in time.
you know,
if the city reclassified what was considered urban,
if they a next it's suburbs,
that's what Leon does in 1852 or Paris,
Dez and 1860 on January 1st or almost anywhere they knew this,
uh,
then that would be one factor.
Then you would have births minus deaths.
I mean,
do you have a natural increase in population?
And then the other thing is in versus out migration.
Do you have more people arriving in this city then leaving it?
I mean,
the people leaving and people arriving all the time.
But if you look at particularly the first half of the 19th century,
to make a generalization,
it was hot in here to make a generalization.
Uh,
more people die in cities than are born there,
uh,
because that he's a very unhealthy places,
which helps create this kind of image of biological sickness that I'll discuss
in a minute.
They'll vote with some conservative commentators from those times.
What do I mean by that?
Well,
the average life expectancy in,
in Manchester counting infant mortality.
So it's a little bit,
uh,
a little bit,
um,
exaggerates,
uh,
was about 19 years old,
so you guys would have bought,
had it,
uh,
or leave the,
in the north of France.
It's the same thing that's pretty young,
but that counts life expectancy.
She made it to the ripe old age of say 18,
then your chances of living longer.
We're pretty great.
Uh,
and and you still had places where we have phenomenal,
uh,
still cases that particular in areas where you have all these spinsters uh,
in Brittany and an Ireland,
you know,
of of old women have,
who live a very long time.
And of course women lived and still live longer than men.
So,
um,
another reason why you have more people dying in cities are,
among other reasons is,
is infanticide.
Ah,
that Ah,
you know,
foundling homes in these big cities.
You named the big city,
Rome,
Berlin,
anywhere you want Saint Petersburg,
Moscow,
they have huge following homes with thousands and thousands of babies abandoned
every year.
One third of those babies die before the end of the next year.
All,
you know,
infanticide,
uh,
the church,
which,
you know,
obviously opposed as a fantasize and obviously opposes abortion in the 19th
century.
Uh,
uh,
what they do is they finally agree to have,
they put in these little things called tour,
They're like,
you know,
this is awful exam,
uh,
example to give and it comes out of an institution that no longer exists,
machine,
city,
but any place that you have those kinds of machines and you put money in and,
and,
and you hope that the window is going to turn around and actually give you your
m and m's.
Uh,
that's what,
uh,
you know,
if you make a crass example,
that's,
that's what,
what are these tours?
Were they in course people do,
uh,
you know,
young women,
uh,
usually unmarried or uncoupled women to abandon their babies instead of exposing
them and having them die,
but falling homes so that you,
you,
you put your baby in this,
you ring the Bell,
you put it in the baby.
And this little thing that turns around.
And then the good sister comes and takes the baby and the foundling home.
And if all goes well,
the baby will be there in a year,
but one third of them are not there in a year.
So you've got a lot of people,
a lot of babies who die.
Uh,
and this increases the mortality rate.
Then you've also got a lot of old people who come into the cities and young
people to beg,
seeking those last vestiges of charity,
you know,
who are clutching at passers by as they will,
as they go to church.
Uh,
and who some people give their money and most of the people don't give them
money.
Often they form part of the community,
which is obviously a case here.
Uh,
you know,
a,
a Yale,
uh,
and uh,
of course a lot of them,
the older people die and they fight it.
The,
you don't,
a policeman going on his rounds in any city in Milan or Turin anyway,
and we're going to find dead people the next morning.
So you've got,
you've got more people die in cities than are born.
They're really in most places,
way into the 19th century.
So the point is obviously that it's immigration immigration that brings,
that causes urbanization and urban growth.
Massive immigration,
usually from the hinterland.
That is the,
you know,
the region around,
uh,
around cities.
I've been in the case of,
of,
of Berlin,
I mean,
Norman germ,
northern Germans from brand new Burger Pomerania,
many,
many polls.
Uh,
moving into Berlin,
uh,
very poor people moving into Berlin.
And the case of Paris,
it's a people who come into,
into Paris or from Normandy or from shampoo,
Tanya,
you know,
or,
or from central France where a lot of them are seasonal migrants and they ended
up living there permanently.
And the 1880s,
you've got a huge wave of Breton's from Brittany who don't speak French.
Uh,
and if you go to the station and won't Parnoss,
you'll see a lot of the cafes around won't Parnoss are named after Bretton
towns.
I love you.
In December,
you look,
I live in the north.
Uh,
and when you still today at that station Montparnasse you'll see the first thing
you see when you get off a train,
there was a sign for the assistance,
public assistance for Breton's and it's in the station and won't Parnass.
Uh,
and this is certainly true.
A Maasais the population or mouth say it includes lots of people from the south
of France,
from provost,
but also who Italians.
Uh,
so this is very obvious.
You know,
cattle lands who move into the people are moving to Barcelona are far more
likely to be cut to la.
Then the RB gets to a deletion or Castilian or something.
This is all obvious.
There's no surprises there.
But the,
the image that people had all of this rapid migration into cities of poor people
because most people who went,
the majority people who move to these cities are poor her than the people that
are already there.
This was in the case of the 1950s and sixties.
And most of these cities,
it's not the case,
the 1950s and sixties,
sort of young professional couples who get enough money to come to rent an
apartment in London,
good luck or to buy an apartment in London or in Berlin or someplace else or
Munich.
Uh,
eh,
but in the 19th century,
you have waves of poor people,
the kinds of people you've seen before who are coming to work as domestic
servants,
uh,
coming to work as,
as,
as day laborers.
In the case of London coming to work on the teaming,
there's that word again,
docs of the Thames River as London is that imperial city looking out on his fast
empire.
Interesting thing about London,
which we had days to talk about this stuff,
but that you,
it's really only in London that you had people of color.
You could find them already by the end of the 19th century,
people coming from,
you know,
from India,
from Pakistan,
what,
what would become Pakistan,
uh,
people coming from the Caribbean.
Uh,
where is it in,
in,
in other cities?
Uh,
uh,
you simply didn't have that.
I mean,
the number of,
of,
of North Africans coming to Paris is merely a trickle,
a really until after a world war one.
Uh,
but anyway,
undertone.
So contemporaries had the,
the idea that,
uh,
that what this whole process was,
and I should have written this on the board,
but you can write it down if you would please call the uprooting and hypothesis
they didn't call it that,
that source of social science from the 1960s that these people were uprooted
from those steady rural roots,
uh,
and you know,
of organized religion and from family support and they're thrown into the
maelstrom under the chaos.
Uh,
uh,
sometimes a creative chaos.
But nonetheless,
perception was a dangerous chaos.
That was urban life.
Uh,
and the result of all of this was that revolution becomes seen as,
as an extension of person action.
Um,
in fact,
some of the bad social science from the 1960s and trying to explain,
you know,
the riots in Detroit and places like that said,
well,
you've got a lot of poor people coming from,
from Alabama and Arkansas,
which is certainly the case of from the South and North Carolina move up to
Detroit and try to get a job in the factories there.
And that,
wow,
they get to the,
to try,
they just freak out because those rural roots have been cut them.
You still see this as various electoral campaigns.
Uh,
even today,
even as I speak,
this sort of idea that you'll cosmopolitanism,
you know,
which is also also by the way,
and almost every language,
sort of a class,
a sort of a code word for antisemitism.
And when people say,
oh,
cities are so cosmopolitan,
they met,
they are full of Jews.
Uh,
and this of triply true in this or antisemitism and racism of eastern,
uh,
eastern and central Europe.
We had so many,
it's such large Jewish population living in cities like Prague,
Budapest,
Vilnius,
Riga,
uh,
just about anywhere you could name.
And then what with the kind of increase in an ethnic populations with the
Estonian ization of Tallinn or the check is a nation of Prague.
You had fewer Germans and fewer Jews and living in,
in those cities,
but you had the server antisemitic discourse that lingers Vienna's the classic
case,
cause Vianna goes from being sort of liberal liberal city in 1850s and sixties.
So sort of the hotbed of antisemitism where the mayor of Vienna at the end of
the 19th century,
a buffoon called Karl Luber says,
I say who's a Jew?
That's one of his more infamous statements.
I say,
declare who's a Jew and who isn't.
And of course,
one wants to understand,
understand how out of Hitler I got as antisemitism.
It really comes from World War One,
but,
but the,
the,
the basis was already laid there by growing up in Austria,
I in,
uh,
in,
in the 1890s and the first decade of the 20th century.
So,
anyway,
but if you think about that,
um,
you know,
does it,
does immigration,
this massive immigration necessarily lead to urban chaos?
Well,
the answer is obviously not a,
because we have the effect that now we know a lot about historians and social
scientists and social geographies and geographers and sociologists,
and it's called chain migration.
Take the case of China,
uh,
that,
people who have studied Beijing,
you know,
discovered a long time ago.
I mean,
I remember this from days when I,
uh,
was studying Chinese history back at,
a less mighty Michigan than it was before.
Uh,
and,
um,
uh,
you know,
the,
all these people pouring into Beijing and the 19th century where they,
they,
they formed native places,
associations a way.
Kwan,
I can't remember if something like that was the term.
Um,
and so it's obvious you get together with people that you know from your part of
China and they are sort of the intermediary areas between you and the city.
Uh,
the Irish are a classic case.
We already have seen how the original leaders scare the hell out of the iris for
a,
of the Irish because there are Catholic and all that.
Um,
so,
um,
but,
but they don't just pour into Manchester and Liverpool in London and sort of
freak out.
It doesn't work like that at all.
They live with their families,
their families make a little money and say,
why don't you come along?
It's the same thing.
Look at the case of Americans,
uh,
you know,
people coming to the United States at the end of the 19th century,
first of all,
uh,
massively from northern Italy and then the 20th century from southern Italy.
You know,
they send money back all the time,
or they,
they,
uh,
in the,
it's very different than the German Germans who came to the United States,
almost never were in contact with their families.
Again,
relatively at same with Swiss,
but the Italians were always stayed in contact.
But in any case,
all of these people,
it's,
it's very sensible.
If you come from,
you know,
California,
it 80,
Yale,
you know,
and you often,
if there are a couple of high schools in La,
they'd send all of these students to Yale.
And if you're kind of,
you know,
you're kind of freaking out when you get to you.
I think God,
all these people,
what,
whatever,
they're also smart or whatever.
Uh,
and then,
you know,
the next thing you do is you go to people that you wouldn't even say hello to in
high school and say,
well,
you know,
why don't we hang out tonight?
Or something like that.
Uh,
and,
and so there,
there Pete,
you find people that come and have origins like you,
geographic or whatever and hang out with them.
It's a logical thing.
It happens every single time.
In the case of people moving to Paris,
Leemoo Zam people from the center part of,
of Paris,
of France called the,
the museum.
Uh,
you know,
they live in certain neighborhoods around the center of Paris in the way that
Breton's lived around the guard.
What became the Garmin Parnass,
the station of mole.
Parnoss so this is chain migration.
You see it in Philadelphia,
you see it in London,
you see it in Moscow,
you see it in Saint Petersburg,
you see it everywhere.
But having said that,
that's not the,
that's not the way contemporary is viewed.
This,
um,
just there's just two more.
Okay.
Let me just give you a couple examples of,
of how often well meaning,
but not always.
Contemporaries saw the phenomenon of urbanization and urban growth.
Let's listen to a preacher called James Shergold Boon Minister of Saint John's
church in the Paddington district of London.
This is a sermon and when he's talking about cities,
uh,
he's evoking,
um,
Sodom and Gomorrah,
the very extent of edifices and the very collection of,
of vast masses of human,
um,
uh,
of,
of human beings onto one spot,
humanity remaining what it is bad is what he means,
uh,
must be fraught with moral infection.
They continually use words like infection,
that there's a biological inequality of people,
uh,
with each other that poor are biologically less likely to in a world of we're
Darwin.
And Post Darwin and misuse of Darwin is very important,
uh,
to survive the challenges of illness,
of disease and illness.
The cholera carries way poor people more than rich people.
He says,
I have to go back to the good minister.
Cities are the centers and theaters of human ambition,
human cupidity,
human pleasure.
On the one side,
the appetites,
the passions,
the carnal corruptions of man are forced as in a hot bed,
uh,
into a rank and file luxuriance and countless evils,
which would otherwise have a feeble and difficult existence are struck out into
activity and warm.
This is biological contagion.
This is a disease metaphor constantly by mere contact with each other on the one
side,
on the other side,
many constraints and safeguards are weakened or even withdrawn.
This is what I mean by leaving those imaginary rural routes in which solidarity
with considered to be automatic and family support.
So very,
very important in cities.
He goes on,
there is a complication of evils.
Um,
external forces cooperate,
cooperate within word desires.
You can conquer those inward bad desires in the countryside,
but all is lost in the demon rum of moral corruption.
That is the reality is from urban life.
Well,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
search.
Harold Shaw,
who was police chief of Manchester,
describe the residents of industrial cities.
These quotes come from an excellent book by,
um,
uh,
a guy at,
at,
at Rutgers Camden called a lease.
Um,
who's a wife teaches at Penn.
Uh,
he called,
uh,
the,
the residents of industrial cities such as his own as the debris,
which the vast,
we're a pool of human affairs has deposited here in one of its Eddie's
associated,
associated but not United contiguous,
but not connected.
That's a perfect,
a description of,
of the uprooting a hypothesis that there's nothing you can do,
uh,
to save people,
from,
uh,
their selves.
Or to take an example from Paris because I'm going to talk about Paris in
awhile.
Um,
in the 1830s as certain vehicle off to the loo ne quite forgettable,
exclaimed how ugly para seems after one year,
uh,
away.
How one stifled in,
uh,
these dark damp,
narrow corridors damp.
Again,
that's a tour,
a keyword and all this which we were pleased to call the streets of Paris.
One would think that it was an underground city,
so sluggish in the air.
So profound the Obscurity and in thousands of pee in it,
thousands of people live bustle frong in the lick.
Liquid darkness like reptiles in,
uh,
Maher in a marsh,
um,
or Victor Hugo,
a cities like forests have their dens in which hide all the vitalist and most
terrible monsters.
Uh,
well they're all this ferocious,
it couldn't be anymore condemning then a particularly in,
um,
in Germany where the whole sense of,
of Heimat,
of having a hometown of,
of being attached to a particular space,
uh,
and all of the corruption that comes from,
from big cities,
and you see this over and over again or take New York.
Here's another reverend,
the Reverend Amery de Mayo who attacked the city.
All the dangers of the town may be summed up here of that here,
withdrawn from the blessed at influence of nature that is out of the country and
set face to face against humanity.
Mankind loses his own nature and becomes a new and artificial creature and
unhuman cog in a social machinery that works like fate.
Again in Zola,
the theme of faith is terribly,
terribly important of destiny.
Along with his,
you'll see along with people that have those,
uh,
or if you read others a lot to have the bad genes,
they've got the drinking genes or,
uh,
or,
or whatever.
Um,
you find all this,
uh,
um,
appalling stuff.
Um,
or,
um,
uh,
here's another one,
a in a book,
a lecture in Nate in 1844.
And the young Americans,
the city's drain,
the country of the best part of its population,
the far with youth of both sexes.
They go into the town and the country is cultivated by so much inferior class.
Well,
it Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
that was the image.
And of course,
all of the revolutions,
I have a lot to do with that,
Simon.
I can't find my wand.
Is it up there?
Ah,
yes.
It's not blah,
blah,
blah.
Can you,
can you do it or,
uh,
yeah.
Thanks.
Okay.
Now let's look at an example of this.
I'm sorry,
I can't click the,
I'm just going to have to wave my hand for Netta.
Clear something or jump up and down.
Um,
now I want you to look at Paris and thinking about what I've said.
Ah,
this is Paris in 1839,
uh,
compared to London,
I didn't have time to talk about this in London.
You can walk,
you can walk miles and you're still staggering around looking for the next tube
stop.
Ah,
cause it's about three times as big,
at least three times as big.
Physically Paris,
1837,
you could walk from the Arc de Triomphe,
which is up on the left to the end in about an hour and a half.
Uh,
and this is before the inner suburbs are a next for tax reasons,
but also for reasons of imposing order on the troublesome periphery.
And this is part of the lecture.
So what you've got is if you don't pair,
so all,
it doesn't matter if you don't know Paris,
here's the garden of Luxembourg.
You've got the two wheeler wreath up along the sand there.
You've got your basic San River,
or you did have three islands.
Now they're about to,
they submitted that one over.
You'll sound that we,
they're just not one of the grace of tourist traps and in a Western
civilization,
but it's still beautiful.
And there are a CTA with old Notredame,
right in the middle.
You've got an enormous population.
You've got an in the central district,
three times the density of population that you have.
Now why are we have apartment in the Ma?
Hey,
a couple blocks up from,
uh,
from to dom and,
and,
and the density there in 1840s in this neighborhood was called Alfie then.
It was three times what it is now.
So you've got this enormous implosion of people into the center from the
provinces.
Next one,
please
hold.
And now this is the reason I put this up here.
This is the first photo of Paris.
This is what you call the daguerrotype that got Tepe.
And then I can identify,
this is,
I'm sure not the only one,
but this is the,
uh,
the full bull.
Her full boar is an English word too,
as well as French.
It means,
uh,
it's sort of an extension of the town.
It's a difficult etymology.
It doesn't really come from false bull,
but from other things.
It's beyond the walls.
But this is the first one.
This is also from a buddy is about 1837 now all Smollen they all station until
like he built these boulevards that became the staging ground for the so called
belly pork.
But there were also boulevards anywhere like around,
because the boulevards were,
were the walls had once been Vienna is a great example.
The rings around Vienna where the rings that were,
were the,
had been where the walls were that were knocked down as the city city group.
Uh,
in Berlin you find the same thing.
next please.
MMM,
this is cheating.
A little bit unhealthy.
This is just an unhealthy,
this guy,
this is an 18th century hat.
Look at the guy.
There's a 19th century guy looking for aggressively for the 19th century with
the worst WildFit.
This could be the restoration actually,
and he's going to get hit by it's raining,
he says,
but it's not as a chamber pot being dumped on his head.
In the 1860s,
only about 10% of,
of of buildings had water above the second floor.
Next please.
Um,
this is
by a guy called Charlotte [inaudible] on it doesn't matter,
but the point of this is this a CTA and there is no true dom there before viva
la La Lou,
Duke's big flash,
you know,
aspire on it.
The point is that before the rebuilding of Paris,
this was among the most densely populated parts of Paris at the end of the
period that is 1870,
it's the least densely populated part of Paris because they bet member of
capitalism in this state,
they build government buildings.
Well,
the hospital,
oh,
tell jurors,
one of them,
the prefecture of police,
which would be have all the fighting around it.
In 1944 in August,
I was built as well.
So,
uh,
these places,
I disappear.
And the more one of the more important more was here also.
And so that was sort of again,
gave the idea of,
of the disease of the center city.
Next,
please.
MMM.
Name those people.
There we go.
Paris in the left eye.
It,
what if the 1850 Paris on the right,
they're all running together.
Uh,
but you see there's a lot more people and you have the growth though that the
filling in of the center and you've got the periphery with the emergence of the
suburbs and it's the suburbs that have increasingly poor people living in them
who can't afford to live in the center of Paris.
That's the big difference.
That's a big,
big difference.
You have a customer's barrier around Paris.
Every time you bring things into the city or any other friends that you have to
pay taxes on them.
A six pack of Beer,
you pay a tax,
you have more space outside the city walls.
So that's where you build factories.
You're near the canal into railroads.
The center city throw with the unwanted industries,
the dirty industries,
soap,
chemicals,
et cetera.
Outside Paris doesn't de industrialized,
you still have the garment industry,
but the dirty industries,
the big industries down on the outside and that's where your labor force lips so
that how different that is than Philadelphia or Detroit where you already had
all this space and you've got the population moving into big central areas and
essentially staying there.
Um,
now to be sure the United States,
we have,
you know,
you have places like a very small part of New Orleans.
You've got San Francisco,
you've got Beacon Hill or you got a Manhattan,
you've got sort of places where you've got a lot of wealthy people living in the
center city.
But places like Detroit or more are more really common of the American
experience.
Uh,
next please.
And I can remember when I was a kid,
I was younger than you,
I think going to a Yankee Tiger double header in 1967,
uh,
Roy White play third base a and w w we walked out in the city was on fire of
Detroit because of the riots and it's still all burned out there.
And,
uh,
one of the interesting things was Gross Pointe Michigan,
which is a very fancy place.
We heard a lot of students here from gross point,
I'm not,
I'm not dissing Grosse Pointe Michigan,
but they,
the municipal council try to figure out a way that,
that you couldn't get to gross point from the ceremony.
Detroit unless you had a map,
unless you really knew how to get there,
try to keep them.
That is the poor people of the center from going to the suburbs and the,
and the,
you know,
the upper classes of gross point armed themselves with our hunting rifles.
And you know,
uh,
just to ask the constables had in central London in 1848,
I mean that spacial juxtaposition is incredible.
Next,
oh,
here we go.
Those were lots of people in the center.
The theme here is overcrowding.
Uh,
the,
here's the market of the innocence.
It was this call.
Now it's down by the form,
the owl.
Lots of people,
uh,
than the big market.
[inaudible] built a would later be torn down,
but lots of people in the middle.
That's a theme.
Next please.
And the root pom in 1860.
Now these are really old medieval buildings.
And of course a lot of them get destroyed by,
by,
by the rebuilding a next please.
Um,
well this is a good one because this is one of the streets that would disappear
and you could say,
well,
what the hell is he talking about?
Where all those people,
well,
if you have really good eyes,
you can see that there are a few people here because of these long exposures,
there's actually some people standing there,
but this had already been condemned to be destroyed rather like the root
transmit Anya,
that it had the part of the collective memory of the massacre there.
What does this in the center,
what's a ditch down?
Which sewage when there were some sewers in Paris,
but it was very unhealthy.
And in these areas,
this is right near the pump.
The,
all that is in the sort of center left,
uh,
eastern part of Paris,
that,
that the,
uh,
the people just get destroyed by the Colorado in 1832 and again in 1849 and
again in the 1880s in 1884 fundamental inequality before death of,
of the poor.
Uh,
and so this street,
uh,
this is actually a great photo.
This is by a guy called Sean [inaudible] who went around and took pictures of
these neighborhoods that we're going to disappear.
Don't worry about the names,
so no worry about the streets.
I'm trying just to make a point.
But not everybody lived on those streets.
And the second empire that is 1852 to 1870,
Napoleon,
the third people lived it up and a lot of us,
a lot.
His novels are really kind of amazing about that.
And,
and uh,
uh,
he didn't like a Louis Napoleon too terribly much.
This is living it up in a big,
uh,
you know,
a big banquet and a big hotel already.
You can see the wine glasses.
They're starting to put the wine glasses in,
connection with the food.
That's something really comes in the 19th century.
The idea of having,
you know,
red wine with cheese.
So you do have white wine with,
with goat's cheese,
but,
but the other,
or having white wine with,
uh,
most with fish and with follow on,
that kind of thing.
And these are long elaborate banquets,
have one course following another.
I mean,
I can hardly condemn that having sat through a few thousand of them myself.
But anyway,
ah,
there we go.
Uh,
fancy people.
Next please.
Um,
now this is the,
this is the,
this is revolution,
uh,
in 1830.
Now the bourgeois guy,
he doesn't belong there because he never went out there.
Anyway,
I'm Marianne.
This is a highly romantic view of death.
Here's your street urchin there who's still fighting the good fight in 1830.
This is delicate as famous liberty leading the people.
Just an enormous,
enormous painting.
Um,
and then these people look like they're kind of play acting.
They're kind of say,
oh,
well I'm dead now.
And then a few minutes later,
I'm going to get in,
get up again.
This is very romanticized.
Next,
please compare this to methadone.
Yay.
This is a very underappreciated painting.
Again,
the name doesn't matter man.
It meant it meant to him and it does the art people.
But,
uh,
this is called the barricade.
This is only 18 years.
18 years later.
This is 1848.
These has real death.
These are ordinary people.
And again,
look at the gray green,
uh,
the sick quarters.
But,
but this is a,
this is an affectionate look at people who are dying for a good cause in the
center of Paris.
But Louis Napoleon,
Napoleon the third didn't want revolution again.
And since there were barricades in so many of these revolutions,
barricades begin on the day of the barricades in Paris.
What's at 1572 or something like that before this course stokes stokes up.
Um,
he said,
let's build the barricades,
the boulevard so wide that you can't build barricades across them.
In 1944 and in 1968,
uh,
barricades were in the same places often where the revolutionary barricades had
been in 1789 a or an 1848 or in 1871.
Next please.
So these guys,
that's the Polian,
that guy with a pen,
that's [inaudible] who was born in Paris,
but now station parents.
Uh,
um,
eh,
that's he,
he's in the middle there and Louis Napoleon flops a map down and it says big
bill,
big boulevards through this teaming city.
Caming used for the third time.
He does it for three reasons.
One,
two,
three,
one to bring more air into Paris.
More boulevards was sewers underneath them.
Boulevards mean better transportation,
more light.
Secondly,
he does this to increase the flow of capital.
It's not a coincidence that department stores are built on these boulevards and
some of the ones are still there.
The shopkeepers not in your department serves got wiped out and they got really
mad,
very extreme right wing voting at the end of the 19th century.
The ones near the department stores do very,
very well.
And third,
and he says it in his,
in his memoirs,
he builds them New Louis Napoleon,
uh,
Oswald's memoirs I'm talking about,
I wants these built so you can't have barricades.
And he builds these boulevards around and through the traditional revolutionary
areas.
And the result is lots of people pack up and they leave.
Next,
we're going to go through the next fairly fairly quick.
So here's Paris 1855 now a the up there are lovely let Omar Mateen there,
which has a godawful church,
uh,
soccer record built on it after 1871,
those were annexed as suburbs in 1860.
They were inner suburbs,
uh,
next into Paris.
And so this wall here is the limit of Paris today,
but you still have people farming and version these places,
gonadal.
Uh,
but all of that will stop.
And by 1870,
then this is all sort of packed with people and put one of the people were
living in Belvita,
which is on a hill,
uh,
where people who,
many of whom were forced out of the central quarters by higher rents.
And so they are the ones perched on dangerously from the point of view of the
center on the periphery.
And ironically,
as the middle class has moved further and further west,
they lose their contact with ordinary people.
And for a lot of stuff they're reading is based upon,
they don't really see those people up there.
Maybe they walked down the hill,
they can't afford to take the RMD,
boost a horse drawn carriages to be servants in their houses.
But,
uh,
these spatial things are very interesting and you find them in other cities.
Uh,
two.
So here they take the map and they say,
let's build boulevards.
And you don't have to know anything about Paris to know that there,
there wasn't any north.
South,
north is up there southwest down toward me,
a thoroughfare,
and they built boulevard San Michelle Boulevard,
[inaudible] boulevard,
send a knee that goes up to the station of the east with the station of the
north,
right to the left.
Uh,
the 12 up here,
uh,
you know,
the boulevard is help create the kind of star notion.
They 12 means star.
It looks like a star around the arc arc de Triomphe and the big grand crossing
that I'll show you in a minute.
That gives you the west East uh,
uh,
access as well as,
as,
as some other ones too.
So they do a lot of building.
They knocked down a whole hill.
Uh,
this is now where the palace of Trocadero is lots of work employing lots of
people.
So the housing workers like them,
1855 let's look at your,
you're walking through the gallery,
the gallery of machines at one of these world fairs because Victoria had had
when an 1851 lunar points got to have them too.
So he has two,
he has one in 1855 and another one in what is at 66 or 67.
So you're walking along here and you can look at paintings or above all,
you could look at machines,
you can look at things that you can buy these.
That's the principle of these expositions.
Paris is on stage and that's the principle of a department store.
You can walk through a department store and you can buy a,
you know,
49 different kinds of shawls ranging from very cheap ones.
Two,
uh,
two very expensive ones.
It's the same principle.
And so the boulevards are really an extension of,
as my friend Philip Nord once argued and solve a lot of other people of,
uh,
these department stores themselves and they become sort of the staging area for
what became known as the belly pork.
It wasn't so bad battled for people that didn't have any money because those
were hard economic times.
And these department stores still still exist.
I mean,
the bash VA a bit bizarre.
Lotos veto still exists in Paris.
Beaumarchais there's a terrific book on Beaumarchais by Michael Miller on,
on the Beaumarchais.
It's still there.
And,
and,
and Zoloft called them the cathedrals of modernity.
And already in 1850s,
they had singing groups,
uh,
singing Christmas carols at Christmas.
Uh,
people would come,
they couldn't afford to buy anything and just be part of the spectrum.
Paris became a spectacle in itself and the boulevards we're part of that.
Um,
and this,
this,
these aren't very good prints but,
but it's called,
this is called the,
he was so important it became to ost man.
Something was to bulldoze it.
Maybe to Ma to Mirman something will be to drink a good bottle of coke to Rome.
Maybe one day.
That'll be my,
I'll,
maybe I'll get a French verb.
But anyway,
awesome.
I'm just kidding.
Oh,
smart.
that's mine.
Oh,
it was Mondays.
That's y'all is to bulldoze something.
Um,
and so this is called the Osman his ass.
Y'All have a neighborhood and here these people are getting the equivalent of
about $10 forced out of their houses.
They've got their dog,
they've got everything.
They own their look at the mattress.
Mattress is the last thing you ever pawn.
There's the mattress and they're leaving.
And then the next one please is,
this is called Bozeman part too.
And here you've got your ost money and Vista.
You've got the big boulevards with all of this.
These not then so fancy.
Uh,
um,
uh,
you know,
railings,
balcony railings,
the real fancy ones come later in the third republican.
This is really a San Augustine is a hideous church or some people really like
it.
My different Bob Herbert thinks is not bad,
the art historian,
but this,
this is almost mine,
is that that's you know,
have a corridor,
part two of a neighborhood.
Next please.
And you've got people building.
That's the tour was on shock,
which is still there.
A lot of these are little teeny people who were from the center part of France
or the builders.
So everybody's aware of this building.
And then here you can say,
how are we going to get from 0.1,
which is done by the sin,
the root of Rivoli,
which has been expanded.
How do you get to this new opera?
They're building?
Well first you tip off your friends.
So they make a lot of money on the deal,
knowing what to sell and what to buy.
And then you take a ruler.
You didn't have to be an architectural genius.
You draw a straight line.
That's what I mean by imperialism of the straight line.
Next please.
You're getting to the opera and there you can see it rising up.
Garnez were operate,
rises up out of the smoke or the cloud of destruction.
I'm getting carried away next please.
And there is being built.
Yeah.
And there it is.
You are here looking at what now is the largest concentration of pickpockets in
the western world.
Uh,
cause there's an American Express right near there and you see all these
Americans,
they've got their big wall says,
where's the American express deer walk right over here.
You know,
their wallets or out of there before they hit the top stair step of the metro
and he,
his baby's gone.
Uh,
anyway,
uh,
that's the,
well that's,
there we go.
That,
that's the plus one dome down there.
Uh,
next please.
And then there it is in 1900 here again,
imperialism,
a straight line there.
You've got,
uh,
oh,
maybe I'll do a thing on a,
I know blowing up this building here a while ago sometime.
We'll come back to this maybe.
Um,
anyway,
there you go.
Now here's the great crossing in the center of Paris.
This is,
you're crossing from,
uh,
from Ila of CTA here and you're going up.
Here's the Gao.
The less the station to the east there.
And this way you're looking down east that there's the tourist on jock and it,
but what's the only point is,
is that they expand this down toward Santa Antoine,
the full board San Antwan where the revolutionaries were in 1848 and where they
were an 18th,
I in a 70,
89 and where they were in 1792 as well.
And at other times in the French revolution,
1830,
for example,
there are down there.
So that's the big crossing point.
Let it go on the quasi community.
Uh,
and there's the guard,
the less sex.
When I see that station,
it's so sad cause that's where all the people drinking champagne.
When in 1914 shouting up our bear,
just as in the hope been off in Berlin,
they were shouting,
shouting,
not poppies.
And of course they don't come back and it's so many people,
uh,
Jews were deported from here.
If they weren't sent from the golden door to draw.
See,
uh,
if there was on the direct line to Auschwitz or the other deaf camps,
they went through the station,
next arrested by French police making 40 to 1943.
He builds layout the big market.
And I mean,
my friend Vince and Scotty who teach us in here afterwards,
uh,
you know,
he,
he would,
he would do a better job on this.
But,
but I do remember since I was first time I was ever in Paris,
I was,
I was know how old it was,
a older or younger than I once was and uh,
anyway,
than I am now or younger than everything will be or whatever the line is.
Uh,
and I met,
I met somebody on a bus in Germany and she kindly,
she was a sculpture,
so she kindly invited me to stay in her apartment all and up and up.
It wasn't a real problem.
Uh,
but she took me down in the middle of the night to see this place and the see
the restaurants where you could,
you know,
where you'd see this or wealthy people eating.
And the butcher's with their,
their smocks covered with Beaujolais and also with,
with animal blood.
And it was really cool.
And then they tore this down.
They tore it down to build a whole bunch of unsuccessful places and you know,
filthy destruction of a monument.
Uh,
we need Vince here to here to do this.
And people chained themselves to these things says,
can't you leave just one?
So people see you.
People would know what these are like.
Can't you leave just once and know we can make some money here.
We can get in.
You know,
soon we'll have Mcdonald's all over the place.
we'll make some money and they got rid of them.
None of them left.
It's a tragedy.
But Anyway,
oh,
someone built those.
I'm not a big of a smart guy,
but if you want,
this is right around the corner from us.
But here's a building,
uh,
with sort of more third republic.
But this,
these are the buildings that he built along the boulevard is next.
Please got a rocket on if you follow art history,
you know there's everything in this painting by Chi book that shows the
anonymity.
It's called Paris with the effect of rain.
And it's right here on this plots,
which is where two boulevards come together.
And that's part of the thing too,
where you got your basic middleclass,
people that were carrying umbrellas,
they are disconnected.
They would never say hello to each other and they're crossing this intersection
that that becomes part of the heartbeat of urban life or something dramatic like
that.
Next please.
Uh,
and so you've got these boulevards and this already existed because it was where
the walls and once Ben,
this is the boulevard.
Moma next please.
Oh,
math.
They were suppose to be another one there.
Anyway,
no problem.
Am I scrub?
If you are flying around over head,
you would look down here.
Here's no to dom.
There's the all up,
up in that direction.
There's the truth of Sassal piece.
You see the big crossing points,
the big boulevards that have been built.
Here's the big old crossing point there,
the tourist on shock,
Bird's eye view of all of this.
I what I left out was a Bizarro of that was aros image of the exist from that
same point where he painted an impression is painted.
Uh,
because of their interest in light and her first view and all of that.
There's a lot of important pay paintings of this.
So Renoir,
I didn't like,
didn't like these boulevards.
You said they look up,
they're lined up like troops at a review.
And that's the most appropriate image of the centralization of state power.
And speaking of state power,
what happens in the Paris commune in 1870 1870 is that he's 71 is that ordinary
people in Paris take arms as you know,
and they build barricades across these places.
Next please.
And then the troops of,
of the provisional government from Versailles,
appropriately enough coming and they use the same boulevards,
the extension of the rude Rivoli.
They're loose and Antwan to go and gun down ordinary people.
25,000 of them.
Welcome to the 20th century.
In 1870 when you were guilty for whom you were a party to the moon that they
could,
Pablo Paris,
everybody was guilty,
said a prosecuting attorney next place.
But the spatial aspects of this are important.
This is right.
That's Madeleine.
It's just a lot of destruction.
Here's money watching or his depiction of a woman,
women being shot.
There were these images that are rumors that women incendiaries we're burning
down property,
the wealthy buildings of the property that they petro lose the female
incendiaries and Manet did one and sorted Kobe.
Uh,
next please.
And finally,
that's real death.
Those are a rather small people in tiny caskets have just been mowed down
because they who they,
they were,
who they were,
uh,
that is poor and in people's Paris.
And they systematically targeted areas like bell veal because they were
identified with the left.
If we could speed to these next few and then we'll be outta here next please.
Um,
and here again,
those are the boulevards with the old gates.
Now there,
but here,
here's what I mean by left by,
by,
by East West.
And then in the north western part of Paris,
the sort of people were moving into slightly better buildings and in the
northeast,
uh,
more rural looking ones just on the outside,
the,
the laundry of combat.
We know this after 1900 because there's a reference to the metro in the metro
didn't open till 1900,
so this is probably about 1912 actually there.
So,
uh,
people on the periphery coming into pawn there a pawn their mattresses and
here's the gates when you're outside again,
why all the factories on the outside,
all the ordinary people because life was cheaper out there.
That's why out beyond mole Parnoss or all these cafe areas that are still in
Paris now,
but we're ones out there because it was cheaper to be out there at the end of
her sad,
short drunk in life as your vez in less Hamar goes out to hook on the periphery
on the boulevard that she gets poor in pores or allow us so well the spatial
aware of the spacial concomitants of all of this.
So this is what it was like passing through the barrier and it's outside that
the red belt exists.
It's outside of all of Vienna is a classic example.
In the 1930s you've got the army blasting,
firing cannons against the working class housing perched on the outside of a of
town sire said,
uh,
one of the ministers to Louis Felipe,
those using,
so those are those factories that you're allowing to be built on the,
on that around Paris,
on the outskirts will be the cord that strangles us one day and it's on the
outskirts in these industrial suburbs that had once been producing for you of
Cherries for the urban market and fruit.
But now were there factories,
it's there that the communist party did so well,
the 1920s in 1930s and even beyond it,
because they provided social services,
they defended people,
they'll call the [inaudible] people that they had inappropriate places to live.
And it was so that again,
it was what I mean by center versus periphery and the sense of not belonging to
the center of not belonging to the center see the same thing.
And people living in inside of American cities of not belonging to prosperity
can allow the formation,
can contribute to formation of a cultural associate.
T have kind of a sense of not belonging creates a sense of belonging is we are
rejected but we too can become powerful.
And the spatial aspects of this are terribly,
terribly important.
And look at the riots and in the suburbs and they in a 2005 we don't have time
to talk about that.
But that's a fascinating,
fascinating thing.
Different people who are marginalized by the center,
large populations of North Africans and a west Africans and people from the
Caribbean,
but use the same phenomenon.
Center periphery is there.
And last,
and I think I've pulled it off,
if you went westward or this is a,
a Monet,
this is one of the many regattas that on,
yeah.
You know,
you went westward for pleasure,
not Eastwood eastward and you went further and further.
So the middleclass is particularly in the western part of Paris,
plant their flag defiantly in Normandy,
in Dover and in Angove and all of these places there.
Uh,
and is there that,
that the impression is paint the Parisian upper classes,
who,
when you go to Deauville,
you still see all the,
the 75 license plates in the 78 from the Paris region.
Uh,
it's still the place.
So there's a social geography of leisure to that develops a in Paris and as in
these other cities.
And it happens so remarkable in that what was not only the bourgeoise century,
not only as rebellious century,
but above all the urban century where the way in which people lived in very
important ways,
uh,
was transformed.
Thank you very much.
Good luck in the midterm.
See Ya.
Next week.
You on Wednesday.